You will hear some very strange things from
physicists sometimes that according to the
theory of relativity, the passage of time
is an illusion, that time doesn't really change,
that there really is no motion, that everything
is somehow existing all together and frozen.
I find those claims to be, frankly, incredible
and would be more amazing a discovery than
anything that's happened in the history of
mankind to find out that all of change and
all of time and the passage of time doesn't
really happen.
I've been asking myself: How did people come
to think that?
And I think the answer is this: That when
we think about space and time in general relativity,
we try to use the geometrical tools and the
mathematical tools that were developed for
expressing geometrical structure, and that
those tools were originally developed just
for space, like for Euclidean geometry for
understanding the structure of space
around us.
And in space there is no direction.
There is no fundamental, intrinsic directionality
in spatial structure, so you wouldn't naturally
develop mathematical tools to represent intrinsic
directionality.
And what happened is taking those tools that
were developed for one purpose, you then use
them for this other purpose.
For not only describing space but time, and
you end up saying things like, "Oh time is
just another dimension like space."
Time is spatialized.
In doing so, you loose track of the directionality
of time.
You loose track of the fact that time is fundamentally
different from space in that it has an intrinsic
direction to it.
It goes from the past to the future, and we
would never say space goes from the East to
the West or the top to the bottom any more
than the bottom to the top.
What I've been doing recently is developing
a different mathematical way of representing
geometrical structure that has directionality
built into it in a very natural way, that
you can represent both things that have an
intrinsic directionality and things that don't.
And in that picture it looks like the right
thing to say about relativity is not that
is spatializes time which makes the direction
of time very puzzling, but that it temporalizes
space, that really what's fundamental is temporal
structure, is time structure, and that in
a certain sense spatial structure derives
from that.